[Musica]
allora cominciò con le cose certe della
mia vita che ad oggi sono due e sono che
il cambiamento climatico esiste per
davvero ed è la più grave minaccia che
l'essere umano sta affrontando e
affronterà nel futuro e che dormire non
fa assolutamente per me fin da quando
sono bambino infatti mia mamma mi
ripeteva questo mantra chi dorme non
piglia pesci chi dorme non piglia pesci
e così finivo per addormentarmi in piedi
abbracciato ad un balcone d'estate in
judo ecco mi sono sempre chiesto perché
mia madre per spronarmi mi dicesse chi
dorme non piglia pesci
me lo sono chiesto veramente per tanto
tempo
me lo sono chiesto in artico dove sono
stato con la marina militare nel
silenzio dei ghiacci e dove ho ascoltato
letteralmente lo sgretolarsi del
ghiaccio per via del cambiamento
climatico
me lo sono chiesto in frontiera
guardando gli occhi dei migranti e il
dolore dei migranti e le loro cicatrici
fisiche e psicologiche
e me lo sono chiesto nel paradiso della
biodiversità in ecuador dove negli occhi
delle comunità indigene che mi hanno
accolto ho visto la reale sostenibilità
umana quindi poi sono arrivato ad una
conclusione
ho risolto il quesito e l'ho trasformato
letteralmente in una domanda che questa
è che vi faccio oggi che cosa mi tiene
sveglio la notte
pensateci un secondo
30 milioni
e questo il numero approssimativo sono
tutte le persone che nel 2020 hanno
lasciato la loro casa per un motivo
dovuto al cambiamento climatico
inondazioni siccità frane più o meno 41
persone al minuto 30 milioni sono le
stesse persone che non avranno alcun
diritto di essere accolte perché la
convenzione di ginevra che garantisce lo
status di rifugiato nel 1951 non
stabilisce il motivo climatico
ambientale come il mio tipo di asilo
alimento in un altro paese
227 e il numero di attivisti che
quest'anno di attivisti e attiviste che
quest'anno ha perso la vita per
difendere la propria terra e per
difendere i propri diritti
1118 invece sono gli eventi
metereologici estremi che dal 2010 ad
oggi ci sono stati in italia
133 solo quest'anno
2,2 miliardi sono tutte le persone che
non hanno accesso all'acqua nel mondo a
noi sembra facile apriamo rubinetto e ci
arriva l'acqua riempiamo le nostre
bottiglie
2,2 miliardi non hanno accesso a questo
servizio più o meno sette volte gli
abitanti degli stati uniti d'america
61 milioni invece sono i bambini nel
mondo che non hanno accesso
all'educazione di questi 61 milioni 9
milioni sono bambini
quindi doppia violazione di un diritto
umano mancato accesso all'istruzione e
violazione di genere
beh ecco forse vi ho rattristato un po
ma oggi è anche vero che si sente tanto
parlare di sostenibilità e parlare di
sostenibilità e cambiamento climatico
non è facile perché spesso ci scontriamo
con soluzioni che sono soluzioni solo
temporanee manifestare un giorno a
settimana piuttosto che parlare
estrapolare dei dati dai dei report e
metterle in un post utilizzare delle
battaglie
che sono battaglie per i diritti umani e
per l'ambiente e trasformarle in un
prodotto da servire al prossimo brand o
che il prossimo influencer potrà
utilizzare
ecco quelle non sono le soluzioni
servono oggi soluzioni concrete l'unica
cosa che serve oggi è veramente un
attivismo concreto e reale che passa
attraverso la consapevolezza che passa
attraverso la cultura infatti oltre il
70 per cento dei giovani in tutto il
mondo una marea dai 18 ai 35 anni
crede che
maggiore sostenibilità si può sapere
attraverso la cultura della
sostenibilità solo incentivando la
conoscenza della sostenibilità degli
obiettivi di sviluppo sostenibile del
cambiamento climatico
quindi la cultura è fondamentale è il
tema di questo ted e la cultura della
sostenibilità ancora di più oggi è
l'unico strumento che ci permette di
emanciparci realmente tutti e tutte e
che ci fa capire che abbiamo un ruolo
fondamentale nella società in cui
viviamo
quindi tutto passa attraverso
l'educazione no educazione intesa come
mezzo di conoscenza e come luogo fisico
mezzo di conoscenza perché attraverso
l'educazione
sappiamo quello che succede nel mondo
sappiamo che cos'è il cambiamento
climatico sappiamo che cos'è
l'insostenibilità del nostro modello di
sviluppo
attraverso l'educazione come luogo
fisico perché l'educazione passa
attraverso le scuole le università che
sono i luoghi del sapere ma come si
rende un luogo del sapere per eccellenza
come l'università un luogo dove si
pratica la cultura della sostenibilità
lo si fa attraverso
la realizzazione concreta della cultura
della sostenibilità umana e ambientale
rendendo la sostenibilità quindi la
normalità incentivando progetti che
aiutino a riconoscere la diversità umana
e ambientale ancora una volta
ma c'è anche l'altro luogo di cultura
che sono i social network e social
network che oggi sono il centro di
aggregazione massimo che conosciamo beh
attraverso i social network passa
molto del nostro traffico dai social
network apprendiamo tantissimo e grazie
ai social network possiamo
effettivamente creare questa cultura
della sostenibilità consapevole che non
trasformi la sostenibilità in un brand
come dicevo prima il social network cosa
fanno democratizzato dei dati li rendono
possibili e più vicini a tutti e ci
fanno capire realmente quali sono le
politiche climatiche
quindi l'unica strategia e passare
attraverso questi mezzi
essere nei luoghi in cui oggi siamo e
prendere parte a quel cambiamento in
maniera consapevole
appunto avendo ben presente che cos'è il
cambiamento climatico
cos'è lo sviluppo sostenibile cos'è la
sostenibilità quindi quello che facciamo
con i social tutti noi e creare un nuovo
linguaggio universale
io non ho una soluzione a rendere
sdoganare la cultura della sostenibilità
un qualcosa che sia accessibile a tutti
ma questa è la prima è il primo
strumento che mi viene in mente creare
un linguaggio universale che sia valido
per tutti e che ci dia uguale spazio a
tutti ea tutte quindi solo così possiamo
realizzare questa rivoluzione
sostenibile di cui tanto sentiamo
parlare io le uniche parole che sono
riuscito ad accostare a questo processo
umano
sono le parole di italo calvino che
nell'ultima parte nelle sue città
invisibili a due rimedi per uscire dall
inferno il primo è semplice e riesce a
tutti che quello di trasformarsi in
inferno fino a non vederlo più sino a
non riconoscerlo il secondo è quello più
complesso e che serve e che ci aiuta
ancora di più a raggiungere il nostro
obiettivo però è difficile che capire e
saper riconoscere chi e cosa in mezzo
all'inferno non è inferno e dargli
spazio e farlo durare capire chi e che
cosa in mezzo all'inferno non è inferno
e dargli spazio e farla durare beh noi
oggi qui non siamo inferno
e il momento adesso la rivoluzione
sostenibile a comincia adesso quindi
adesso possiamo effettivamente
smuovere le regole e
intesserà ancora di più una cultura
della sostenibilità nelle nostre vite
nelle nostre scuole le nostre famiglie e
con tutti i nostri amici grazie
[Applauso]